normalement à cette période de l'année
barcelone grouille de touristes pandémie
oblige l'emblématique sagrada familia
évident de visiteurs en espagne cette
semaine une partie des travailleurs a
repris le chemin des usines et des
chantiers après deux mois de confinement
mais pour voir le retour des touristes
il faudra attendre l'hôtellerie et la
restauration sont les premières à pâtir
de cette désertion
ce restaurateur a ainsi perdu 70% de son
chiffre d'affaires notre activité a
radicalement changé maintenant le
fonctionnement de notre restaurant se
base uniquement sur la livraison et
vente à emporter grâce aux plateformes
de livraison avec qui nous travaillons
déjà avant nous avons dû nous adapter
moi j'ai dû faire un plan social partiel
la moitié du personnel ne travaille plus
actuellement
les ventes ont beaucoup baissé et nous
sommes dans une situation très dure et
très difficile pas seulement pour moi
mais aussi pour tous les commerces du
coin
l'espagne c'est plus de 83 millions de
visiteurs chaque année
le secteur touristique représente 15% du
pib du pays
si les restaurants peuvent se rabattre
sur la vente à emporter les bars et les
boîtes de nuit sont totalement à l'arrêt
le président de la fédération des
discothèques d'espagne espère un retour
rapide à la normale après avoir mis une
cinquantaine d'employés au chômage
technique
je crois que
nous commencerons pas à ouvrir
normalement jusqu'à des hommes en
octobre novembre mais ça dépend ça
dépend beaucoup de beaucoup de choses si
les hôtels commence à ouvrir normalement
à septembre et octobre on pourra ouvrir
toute la semaine mais c'est les hôtels
offrent ils ont pas de clients et les
boîtes peuvent pas faire des concerts et
les résidences universitaires sommes
part il n'y a pas de race nous ni
d'étudiants américains
alors ça change tout le confinement doit
en principe durer jusqu'au 25 avril mais
madrid a déjà prévenu il pourrait être
prolongé
l'espagne est le troisième pays de plus
endeuillé au monde avec plus de 18000
mort du coronavirus